well the today the villages where the
700 million people are staying I don't
have the different facilities of banking
they can able to solve the different
problems by our telecommunication by
cellular phones tele banking can be
introduced and this technology they can
learn through telecommunication and the
telephone can able to solve their
problems by Terry banking where the main
cities they had their accounts and
through tele banking they can able to
solve their economical problems in the
programs and the facilities they require
and most of their businesses which are
being
they are not able to solve because of
the banking facility is not available in
the villages which will help them
through teluk cellular phones they can
establish links and the banks will be
very happy to provide them these
services thank you very much